what pivotal scene did Elvis star Austin
Butler insist on changing and why'd he
call it out Elvis's mama would be proud
with such projects as strictly ballroom
and Moulin Rouge under his belt it's no
great shock that baz luhrmann decided to
tackle the story of the king of rock and
roll himself Elvis Presley starring
Austin Butler as the titular music
legend Elvis follows his rise to fame
and eventual professional and personal
decline it also takes a look at the
relationships he shared with those in
his life including his partner Priscilla
and his longtime manager Colonel Tom
Parker as well as the condition of the
United States and the world across the
1950s 60s and 70s that's a lot of ground
to cover in one film hence why Lerman
has a four-hour cut that will likely
never see but simply filling out a
checklist of important moments and
events isn't enough this is Elvis
Presley after all one of the most famous
and recognizable musicians ever to walk
a stage or Grayson album cover so
getting it just right is of the utmost
importance thankfully Austin Butler
doesn't phone it in with his take on
Elvis Presley in fact the star was so
dedicated to the production that he even
gave some brutally honest creative
feedback to Lerman regarding a pivotal
scene he found corny in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly baslerman and
Austin Butler explained the process of
pinning down Elvis Presley's speech
patterns and music vocals it was very
daunting at first but just the joy of my
life this proved no easy feat and
required a lot of effort on Butler's
part but they eventually got it down to
a science in doing so they even changed
the scene about Elvis's attempt at
inspiring his Vegas band during their
workshopping of the song that's all
right Mama
I uh I want to try something new
when it finally came time to shoot after
months of rehearsal Lerman recalls
Austin looked at me and was like this
just is corny this is not working it's
fake Lerman instructed the band to play
different notes so Butler could find a
desired sound that sounded more sincere
and true to the role while this tweak
made it possible for the actor to slip
into his role more authentically this
level of commitment didn't come without
a price Butler told collider in June of
2022 that rediscovering himself after
wrapping up his work on Elvis wasn't a
quick and easy thing to pull off he said
that the project required him to
practically isolate and become the
closest to Elvis he possibly could
adding it was really a solid couple
months before I really felt some
semblance of normal afterward I'd never
done something in the way where I just
put my life aside
it's sort of an existential crisis you
know you kind of question who you are
Austin Butler clearly gave his all for
Elvis and wanted to do right by the pop
culture icon and identifying a corny
scene isn't the only way Butler helped
Elvis become the success that it turned
out to be in fact the movie may not have
reached the Finish Line at all if the
actor hadn't pushed for it when the
going really got tough viewers may
recall a frightening moment from early
2020 when Elvis star and actor Tom Hanks
revealed that he had contracted covet
19. as it turns out hanks's illness came
right around the time that Elvis was in
its most crucial stage of production
with one of the film's lead actors out
of action things quickly went sour and
it even seemed to baslerman like the
film was going down in flames during a
speech at the 2023 Palm Springs Film
Festival Lerman spoke about this
tumultuous time in Elvis's development
saying the film fell apart I couldn't
keep the cast together Lerman recalled
that he subsequent went to Butler and
told him the film was over and
production had shut down however Butler
remained Resolute insisting that he
wouldn't exit the film until it had been
finished lorman went on he inspired me
to go back to Tom and say you've got to
do this